ce serait trop vaste que de parler de
mode africaine moi par exemple je viens
d'un pays où il ya il ya 250 tribus 250
groupes ethniques donc comment est-ce
qu'on veut parler d'une mode qui couvre
tout un continent sachant que le
continent contre 55 pays donc la mode
africaine ça veut dire quoi concrètement
[Musique]
c'est arrivé du land avec la colline
colonisation avec l'arrivée de l'autre
bon c'est vrai que le panier eu ses
lettres de noblesse en afrique se
l'approprier on l'a inspiré en la
valorisant le portrait bien mais au delà
du pagne avant le pagne on avait toutes
sortes de fibres de textile on avait le
coton on avait toutes sortes de choses
qu'on faisait déjà et moi c'est avec ça
que je travaille
[Musique]
dans les cei chacun de défendre cette
africanité finalement en travaillant sur
des matières naturelles en travaillant
sur les esthétiques à ces différences
euro bondit quand un aspect identitaire
très fort et il faut pas catalogué la
mode dans un continent autre audi celle
là c'est la mode africaine celle là
c'est la mode européenne la mode elle
est universelle aujourd'hui une femme
blanche le pnp porter facilement
une espèce de bouillon de culture en
pleine évolution
[Musique]
quand est ce que la bad africaine n'a
pas influencé le monde de la mode
beaucoup viennent en afrique aujourd'hui
pour s'inspirer de ce que les créateurs
africains font la créativité africaine
c'est toujours exporté énormément que
l'on reconnaisse ou pas que l'on s'est
inspiré des africains
[Musique]
une inspiration convoi des imane ayissi
du cameroun qu'on voit des virgiles ablo
et tous ces créateurs en fait qui nous
représente avec tellement de fierté avec
tellement d'intégrité ça nous inspire et
ça nous ouvrons la voie aussi